xiamen ahamada from to achieve ah okay
so everyone can hear me well yes I did
where you from here no vimala of taking
it from dancing ha boo that's great yes
I do and how large is your driving yeah
40 50 right no 46 they send food i'm a
36 yes 46 the mamala that's a good size
so over the right here please everyone
please over to the right some places
have a special horror and a cc is one of
them it radiates the charm of one of
Christianity's most beloved saints
we're in Italy's Umbria region north of
Rome it's Friday morning and the weekend
is beckoning the main square of Assisi
is undergoing a transformation for two
days the town will return to the Middle
Ages and celebrate its origins the
festival of kalindi module
oh brother Tomas is a German Franciscan
he lives in Assisi I'm love to show his
fellow Germans the town status is kinda
fileice newseum the town is not a museum
mangy people live here see this they're
also got hit Steven talkin that'll be
especially noticeable during the next
couple of days when sec celebrates the
medieval festival of colouring demands
young big of a sec I'm missing yesterday
new physics that's something the
townsfolk's staged themselves in her
friends it's not publicized very much
it's a festival for the town and its
residents and it's part of the town's
identity guard listening good tour
Assisi was a bustling medieval town when
Francis was born here in 1182 but nobody
could have guessed that he would make a
CC world famous and that his life would
be an inspiration for millions of people
down through the centuries
his father was a wealthy merchant and
Francis grew up in luxury at first he
set asides on a military career but then
changed his mind he had a dream in which
God called him to renounce all his
worldly possessions and live a life of
penance this young man's extraordinary
charisma attracted others and soon a
community developed around him that
eventually gave rise to the franciscan
order when san francis died in 1226 he
was buried here on the hillside but such
was the prestige of a new Franciscan
Order but soon a magnificent church was
built to house his remains it was a
strange paradox for the man who loved
poverty and simplicity
mungkin disease to begin deforesting we
could start by asking what kind of a
person francis of assisi was that's
monkeys invention just two years after
his death his followers began building a
church to house his tomb that was
extraordinary and shows us what an
impact his life had on people feel the
legal go back right from the start
Francis drew people to Assisi thousands
wanted to join his community to visit
his tomb to be near him that's one I
think top common be in a sign this
church bears witness to their influence
to the impact his life had on people he
does Laban this Francisco sin falta tots
almost one is idly fastian
the tomb itself is in the crypt below
the church touching and its simplicity
like sin Francis himself members of a
Franciscan Order can be found here at
every hour of the day praying at the
grave of the man who inspired and
continues to inspire the Franciscan way
of life the Basilica comprises an upper
church and a lower one begun as a
Romanesque structure it was later worked
on by several great architects of the
Baroque period the magnificent 14th
century frescoes in the upper church are
the earliest depiction of the Saints
life
giotto began painting than just six
years after Francis was proclaimed a
saint in 12 28
Sgt of mine envious it's the story of a
journey Francis's journey of faith when
he set out he didn't know exactly where
he was heading Evelyn delete a BF he
thought he'd like to become a knight but
he wasn't sure and then he had an
encounter with God on the building site
of a church Christ was alive and present
there and Francis encountered him
personally speaking for me there's an
encouraging lesson in this we shouldn't
stop asking questions about our life
about what we believe it's worth
continuing the journey even if the path
itself is not always clear Francis
didn't see everything clearly from the
start he needed time he had to search
and ask questions she had to find his
path in life and then as time passed it
became clearer it's God I don't be at
stoically hammington summit Francis's
choice of a simple lifestyle is in stark
contrast to our hectic world but the
Basilica doesn't brow beat us with
morals brother Thomas points out it's
psychological subtleties
the stiction alchemy the parochial even
in the baroque church there was a
lightness for instance here at the front
or the altar is placed on the business
model Fire doesn't we celebrate the
Eucharistic banquet here a foretaste of
eternal life and above the altar we see
the wedding at Cana which also
represents entry fee it's a symbol of
eternal life and logically we have to
ask why is it more difficult to win
people for the faith today if eternal
life is like a banquet at which the wine
never runs out I'd like to see the
person who doesn't want to be invited me
to the mission that's pretty obvious see
in dead earnest canadean most strikingly
shiner gnarly be to opt owner
five million tourists from all over the
world come to a city each year
apart from the famous Basilica they want
to see the town not least because of its
charming traditions and festivals
especially kolenda module everything's
ready let the festivities begin
residents from the two sections of
assisi dress up to compete in historical
costumes the upper town against the
lower town
the winners are those who put on the
best show the contest has its origins in
an historical dispute a rivalry that
split the town in the late Middle Ages
on day one the flags of assisi united
and harmony a blessed in san francis
basilica combining the religious and
secular aspects of the festival
this annual ritual is actually quite new
it was introduced in 1954
the historical costumes are very
elaborate and richly decorated it's all
a bit reminiscent of Italian opera
after the ceremony the Basilica falls
silent when people wanted to share his
life Frances is said to have quoted a
passage of some matthew's gospel to them
if you wish to be perfect go and sell
your possessions and give to the poor
and come follow me the call to
evangelical poverty in the footsteps of
Christ this is the path that brother
Thomas has also chosen as easiest finish
I'm vistaca invade fall apart at CC is
very important to me are violent in a
bunch of chemical it's precious because
it proclaims a message that is part of
my lines ganna vedecci apart i like the
communicable it's my personal experience
with regard to the faith it's ones
relationship to the church it's
important everyone has their own
experience and I hope of course a
positive one mukhi have eyes are not
really well that's for me and I think a
cc is a place where lots of people can
experience what the church is and what a
life according to the gospel nice what
being a Christian means nothing if until
you must sign / daughter
the Franciscan mother house the orders
headquarters is situated within the
walls of the Basilica today the order
has some 30,000 members after the
Jesuits and Benedictines it's the third
largest order in the Roman Catholic
Church brother Thomas shows us how the
friars live in Assisi 12 square meters
with a balcony it's a bit like a
student's dorm books are among the few
possessions of Franciscan is allowed to
call his own
so eglish shouts anglish by hidden from
all the rooms are very similar to you
doubt society knows each brother has his
own room and the things he needs to work
that's all we also have a fairly large
library here where all the books are
kept that don't fit into our rooms oh
man today the computer is our main tool
all our correspondence reservations for
guided tours and all the planning is
done on the computer do you have yahoo
for fuel 150 tons of blonde rice early
pray and then guide a group of pilgrims
that's the life of the Franciscans here
unless of course a very special guest is
announced as on October the 4th 2013
when the crowds gathered on the square
in front of the Basilica on some
Francis's feast day and the special
guest was none other than Jorge Mario
bergoglio Pope Francis himself the
pontiff from Argentina is the first ever
to have chosen a name of Elah Poverello
the little poor man from Assisi and he
came to pray at his namesakes tomb
with a life of poverty and simplicity
sin Francis tried to fulfill his mission
to rebuild the church and the Pope from
the end of the world is also trying to
rejuvenate the institution he came to
Assisi as a pastor and a priest city
church the basilica was hushed as
Francis celebrated Mass have invited a
few years villa toscana Apaches here
convoy if he call a cheetah Neela save
you the pops taught Allah he greeted all
the Franciscans brothers personally he
always does that money visit to
monastery his schedule was very
demanding he visited all the important
sites in one day and he was pretty tired
in the evening he got very close to the
video episode leash I lived what was
brother Thomas's impression of the visit
ina sites was not Jewish moscoso does
well on the one hand it was very special
but on the other it was perfectly
ordinary so because this Pope is so
unplanned buoyant in his manner when he
celebrates mass he's very quiet and
thoughtful he doesn't use the liturgy to
make theatrical gestures dr. Lewin a few
words but when he mixes with the people
is very lively he stopped his car in
Assisi for instance to have coffee with
some people at a coffee bar apparently
they had hung up a banner inviting him
so he stopped the car of course it was a
nightmare for the security people when
the woman came out of the bar with a cup
of coffee for the Pope's not supposed to
drink anything give them to him by an
unknown person but he does that kind of
thing and people are delighted when they
meet him personally or in system does
all so passengers pagina
today the Franciscans are all over town
and they seem to be enjoying themselves
wild boar in every conceivable form
truffles and cheese the Umbrian cuisine
is delicious icici is especially famous
for its confectionery dozens of shops
sell desserts that make your mouth water
brother Thomas relax as his Franciscan
modesty and has a field day together
with his friend Claudia he was the king
of sweet temptations OG abbastanza a
typical sweet treat here is ricotta
rather like strudel but heavier it's
made with chocolate and dried fruits as
well as apple and fresh walnuts a
multiple physique and goo boy mains
rolled in pastry just like a strudel
yeah so me younger woman and usually
it's washed down with a glass of liqueur
even with one that's especially made to
accompany our desserts Gordon Pastrana
church bells are often the only sound
you hear in the Upper Town a cc is hilly
and the maze of twisting lanes in the
old town dissolves into fields at the
foot of Monte Sebastian it's a lovely
view which brother Thomas takes time to
enjoy when he's not guiding groups of
pilgrims inevitably it reminds him of
sin Francis in bucegi of dole Matt
Francisco's thi Dunedin FL he had the
most important experiences of his life
in this area down there he met lepers he
prayed in the various chapels and that's
where he experienced those decisive
moments outside the town and this is an
interesting point outside official
church structures there were lots of
churches in Assisi and many
opportunities for pastoral work but he
wasn't drawn to them at this point of
time he was looking for something
different which he found among the
lepers and in the spiritual experience
of prayer would act by do the things I
experienced in life are related to my
faith they can't be separated from each
other hot Elvis MIT meinem leben to tune
with Vytas coming east for an
undetermined
the Franciscans pray twice a day in a
lower church of the Basilica at
half-past six in the morning and at
seven in the evening
I
whereas the followers of sin Benedict
for instance run farms and vineyards
combining manual work and prayer
Franciscans have always been wandering
preachers and pastors
when they settle somewhere it's usually
in towns and cities where the spiritual
need is greatest
on the second day of the cici's annual
festival a piper heralds the start of
the colorful show
the actual contest begins today and the
medieval festival of Kalin dimaggio
reaches its height but first a meal with
the Franciscans and a second private
tour with brother Thomas through his
monastery it used to be something quite
different dimension one dances people
often wonder why this is such a large
buildings deeds actually it's a papal
palace a palace for the Pope and pops
the palace see you see this gate yeah
it's especially large that the Pope
could drive through it in his coach
Conda other than the dimensions of this
building are all related to the fact
that it was built to be a papal
residence well does the paper centuries
the Pope stay there yeah mi vida
garrison seem to theorize idiot happen
today it houses Franciscan friars and
also students the theological institute
here is affiliated to the Pontifical
Lateran University which trains
seminarians for the Diocese of Rome it's
also a center of Franciscan studies and
of modern Franciscan life
you know the audence legal Steen I'm
party you'd leave the rule of our order
includes some things which seem a bit
strange today for instance st. Francis
completely forbade the use of money he
viewed money is something alien to the
real world veidt's nefarious then the
scale money was a privilege of the rich
Francis wanted to live like the simple
people who love that's why he forbade
myeloid this vegan pepita dead us killed
he also forbade us riding horses dust be
alpha it's part of the room give amusing
things that we have to laugh about
because hardly any of us can write then
so it wouldn't be hard to fulfill that
part of the rule I'm problem what
Francis of course meant was that the
horse was the symbol of the rich and
powerful prosperous folk horses
understand to Michigan rise lots of all
happen dimension D hotline fair under
honesty
the refectory the friars dining room is
a hive of activity it's almost dinner
time wine is part of the meal a symbol
of the resurrection because dead grapes
are brought to new life through
fermentation
men from 20 countries live together here
most of them are Italian but there are
also a lot of Romanians and poles
for a Franciscan friary this refectory
is rather grand that's because of its
people history not all Pope's have lived
as modestly as the current one in fact
until recently the lifestyle of the
Pope's rivaled that of the crowned heads
of Europe wasn't as a babes did he I
these paintings are of the Pope's who
had something to do with Saint Francis
our members of our order or had a
special connection to the Franciscan or
two sec modern or that's who I CC hob
well they're not presented
chronologically but according to
popularity and special interest now soon
party or episode of interesa beneath the
large painting of the Last Supper hands
the small portrait of a man who was
popular and of special interest today
Pope Francis did he eat in this room
when he came to a cc or perhaps even
hide a little secret under the table
Vic manja self-avowed the brothers keep
special things there it's more difficult
for us because there are no drawers
under these tables yah yah Mia kinda
Blood Moon didn't it used to be an
important tradition in our monasteries
the old tables had a drawer underneath
but the brothers could keep their false
teeth or pills or other things Skippy's
it was like that on our monastery in
upper bavaria where i lived in the early
90s there was an old brothers in the
community and once when I put the soup
terrain on the table one of them opened
a drawer and took out a sausage that he
had been storing there for several days
he threw it into the soup triumphantly
and said look what I've got she was not
that sisters the copies the last in the
afternoon the lovely town becomes even
lovelier the pretty residents become
even prettier
who will win the trophy this year the
upper town or the lower town to the
visitor this may look like a spontaneous
show but it has all been perfectly
organized and rehearsed the excitement
grows and the tension mounts
some of the contestants have been
waiting all year for this moment while
the other town flaunts extravagant
costumes residents of the Lower Town
score points with their humor
the jury is one over by the funny
depictions of medieval life the calendar
Marja culminates in a frenzy of dance
which everyone enjoys
and when the festival is over a CC
becomes once again but it has been for
centuries the town we associate with
Allah Poverello the little poor man st.
Francis
you